let's get into some news really quickly
netflix uh variety is reporting that
like these new movies are going to come
out every single week in 2021
that's 70 movies wow a year like idris
alba jennifer lawrence the rock ryan
reynolds so many more stars
dictor dictorial
[Laughter]
directorial debuts from lin-manuel
miranda
heli berry gary you've been in the
digital world um
for so long do you think this is just
like again what's gonna happen do movie
theaters come back are we all
sitting in our houses forever what are
we doing no we're humans we need
each other we're yearning for it will it
be a little bit weird when we get fully
back to normal sure it's like coming out
of summer vacation going back to school
movie theaters can come back but they
need to innovate these movies that
netflix are going to put out are going
to be remarkable it's cozy in your home
the popcorn's not as expensive um so i
think innovation
is the future for movie theaters like
why can't a movie night be a hundred
bucks
more like a broadway show but you do
dinner upstairs and then you go to the
movie i think
you're gonna see innovation over the
next decade or two in the movie theater
world but i think this
quantity execution by netflix is
brilliant
i think that in hollywood and in general
in creative land
we demonize quantity we're like what
about quality well quality
is subjective you either like it or you
don't but quantity
is not subjective so while netflix puts
out all these
uh movies and their competitors put out
far less it gives netflix
many more at-bats to hit the home run
that let's say a queen's gambit was
and so i think quantity is demonized in
creative landscapes
and should not in an internet
infrastructure world
well i totally agree with that yeah i'm
just sort of thinking like thanks a lot
netflix like i'm going to be dating my
lazy boy all of
uh okay people aren't just burnt out on
social media media they're also feeling
the zoom drain zoom has changed
everything
and prevention reports that zoom fatigue
is
a new real thing and it happens because
of that little delay on the video call
you know
where it's like a slight gap but you
know that thing you do
you mean like the show we make every day
so you get it yeah well they say your
brain has to work harder
to focus on it psychologists say you
should take breaks between
zooms what do you think i happen to love
zooms now when people say let's have a
phone call i'm like oh it's so 2019. i
agree
i love this face to face what do you
think i think everything
is best in balance and so i'm obsessed
with
zoom as well it's been very efficient uh
i feel the human connection 95
which is far greater than i expected uh
but it's interesting i'm about to roll
out something i know a bunch of people
in the company are watching right now at
vayner x the holding company that has
vaynermedia in it we're doing something
at 1 37 p.m because we have a site
called 137 pm.com
every day at 1 30 7 p.m and starting i
think february 1st for the company we're
doing a 15-minute
uh little live kind of chat
fireside chat drew i'm going to dm you
and invite you to come and talk to the
company
about you know uh diversity and
inclusion or a new strategy we have or
somebody super amazing like drew to make
everybody smile
so for 15 minutes and what i'm excited
about ross is that at 1 37 p.m if it's
15 minutes
that actually means they can't take a
meeting at 1 30 because at 137 they have
to
that means at 1 52 they're done with
this little kind of refresher each day
and it gives them kind of like seven
minutes before eight minutes on the back
end to kind of break up their day
i think you've gotta encourage people to
balance themselves but sometimes as an
organization you need to come up with
little fun cultural things and i think
company leaders have to innovate and i'm
excited about the innovation we're
rolling out
i love that gary vaynerchuk
i am just one of your biggest fans i
would love to be
on any where you ask or call i
am you know i'm drinking all the
kool-aid that you put out there in the
world because it is helping us
navigate how we live our best lives
how we put our best business
feet forward and how we have emotional
wellness
and i just thank you for that because
it's so easy
to trust someone who's doing it yeah and
you are the king
[Music]
you